en estas imágenes grabadas por el
regimiento a soft los civiles trepan por
los restos de la planta siderúrgica de
as hostal luego guiados por vehículos de
la onu mujeres niños y ancianos llegan a
la ciudad de bencina controlada por los
rusos a unos 30 kilómetros al este de
mariupol
natalia trabajadora de la planta es una
de ellas tras haber visto la luz del sol
en dos meses relata el terror que sintió
cuando cayeron las bombas
los bombardeos eran tan fuertes que no
dejaban de caer cerca de nosotros a la
salida del refugio antibombas en lo alto
de unos escalones la gente podía
respirar porque no había suficiente
oxígeno bajo tierra pero yo tenía miedo
de salir y respirar aire fresco
la situación sigue siendo tensa el
comandante del regimiento asof una
unidad de infantería voluntaria
vinculada a la extrema derecha que está
defendiendo el lugar dice que la gente
sigue atrapada adentro
si echas un vistazo a las imágenes de
satélite de s'hostal verás los edificios
completamente destruidos oímos voces de
personas que todavía están vivas allí
apenas es posible sacarlos sin un equipo
especial así que lo necesitamos y
queremos salvarlos
las autoridades ucranianas afirman que
unos 1000 civiles 500 soldados heridos
refugiado en el interior de la inmensa
planta siderúrgica la única parte de
mariupol que aún no ha sido ocupada por
las tropas rusas la ciudad ha sido
objeto del asedio ruso más destructivo
durante el conflicto